Prof: Okay,
this morning we're going to
finish talking about Marx,
and we're going to focus on the
failures of Marxism and the
legacies of Marxism,
and the failures are connected
to the legacies in important
ways that we'll unfold as we
proceed with today's discussion.
I began this already on Monday
by talking about the
difficulties with Marx's
assumptions about scarcity and
superabundance.
And we saw that just as Mill
couldn't banish politics from
politics through the mechanism
of a neutral definition of harm,
Marx is unable to banish
politics from politics by
somehow wishing distributive
conflict could,
in principle, go away.
We saw that that notion of
superabundance that informs his
communist utopia is incoherent
in principle,
and that means that
distributive conflict is endemic
to human society no matter how
much wealth there is.
And some principles for the
distribution of income and
wealth are going to have to be
argued about and defended
regardless of what is produced
in society,
or what could be produced in
society.
The second failure of Marxism
is well known,
but we should,
nonetheless,
mention it,
which is that his historical
predictions turned out to be
hopelessly wide of the mark.
Not only was he wrong in 1830
and 1848 when he thought that
communist revolutions were about
to sweep through Europe.
They were both (a) not
communist and (b) quickly
reversed, in any event,
within a couple of years.
His larger historical
predictions were also wrong.
He thought communism would
come, socialist revolutions,
for reasons that you now know
because we've worked through the
macro theory.
He thought that socialist
revolutions would occur in
advanced capitalist systems that
had become uncompetitive because
of the replacement of
competitive capitalism with
monopoly capitalism,
and in fact where we saw
revolutions bearing the
communist label was in peasant
societies: in Russia,
and in China,
or in Eastern Europe in
countries where it was actually
more or less imposed from the
outside by the Soviet Union
after World War II.
We didn't really see any
society go through the sort of
path Marx was thinking of in his
larger teleological theory of
history,
namely from feudalism,
to capitalism,
to socialism, to communism.
It simply didn't happen.
And as the reversals of the
revolutions of 1830 and 1848
remind us on a smaller scale,
Marx's bigger idea that there's
some purpose or direction to
history seems questionable by
the first decades of the
twenty-first century.
History doesn't go in a single
direction,
and this is a theme to which we
will return,
but you can see movements
toward more egalitarian systems
and then movements away from
egalitarian systems.
You can see democracy created
and then you can see it collapse
into authoritarianism,
so that there isn't a single
teleological or directional
focus of history of the sort
that Marx was looking for.
So on the big predictions,
Marxism doesn't look very good
from the vantage point of the
twenty-first century.
But some of his smaller
predictions were also wrong in
ways that in some respect is
more interesting for our
purposes,
and so I'm going to go back
through some of his arguments
and focus on things that were
wrong with those arguments that
we can,
nonetheless,
draw some interesting
conclusions about as we go on
our way in examining the moral
foundations of politics.
And I'm going to start with his
macro theory and talk about some
difficulties with that,
and then I'm going to go
backwards into the micro theory.
So we're doing the reverse,
if you like,
of what we did on the way in.
We started with the micro
theory and we saw how that
generated the macro theory.
Now we're going backwards
through the macro theory,
and then we will go back into
the labor theory of value and
the assumptions about
workmanship that underlie it
that he took over from Locke and
secularized and modernized,
as you know.
So if you'll recall from
Monday's lecture,
Marx's macro theory was an
invisible hand theory like
Smith's,
except it was a malevolent
invisible hand whereas Smith's
was a benign invisible hand.
And one element of it was the
argument about the potential for
liquidity crises,
that there would be the
possibility that people would
horde money,
that money would stop flowing
through the system,
and the system would thereby
become sclerotic.
It is the case that capitalist
systems have the potential for
liquidity crises,
but one of the things Marx
greatly underestimated was the
capacity of capitalist states in
capitalist societies to address
things like liquidity crises and
other things as well,
we'll see.
It's almost as if he didn't
really take it seriously when he
and Engels said,
in The Communist
Manifesto,
that the state in capitalist
society is the executive
committee of the bourgeoisie.
He underestimated what the
state could actually do to
preserve capitalism.
A good example,
in the early years of this
system was a huge liquidity
crisis in Mexico where the whole
Mexican economy was on the verge
of complete collapse,
but the western governments,
led by the United States,
put together a fifty billion
dollar package to pump liquidity
into the Mexican economy until
the crisis was over,
and they succeeded.
And so we didn't see the kind
of collapse in the Mexican
economy that that liquidity
crisis had the potential to
create.
So the argument about the
potential for liquidity crises
is valid,
but we have no particular
reason to think they can't be
managed once the sources of
liquidity crises are understood,
and governments have the levers
available to them that were made
available to the Mexican
government during the Clinton
Administration in the U.S.
Secondly, Marx has this
argument about the declining
tendency in the rate of profit.
As I said to you,
every classical political
economist believed that there
was a declining tendency in the
rate of profit in market
systems,
and they thought one of their
jobs was to account for it.
They thought it was definitely
the case that there is this
phenomenon, and you had to
explain why it occurs.
In fact, if we look over the
long course of capitalism since
the nineteenth century,
it's far from clear that there
is, as an empirical matter,
a long-term declining tendency
in the rate of profit.
In Marx's case,
as you know,
his story about the declining
tendency and the rate of profit
had to do with the increasing
capital intensity of production.
That as capitalists compete by
relying more and more on what he
calls constant capital,
there's less and less fresh
value created,
and so what capitalist
entrepreneurs do at the margin
to be more profitable in the
medium run makes them less
profitable.
So the capitalist who puts the
spinning jenny in increases his
profits in the short run,
but when there are spinning
jennies in every cotton factory
in the economy the rate of
profit is lower than before the
first spinning jenny had been
put in.
And Marx identified that as the
basic dynamic driving the
declining tendency in the rate
of profit.
Two problems with it;
one is that it assumes there's
this sort of finite number of
industries.
Because you could grant his
argument and say,
"Yeah, it's true that the
rate of profit in the cotton
industry will fall as it becomes
more and more capital
intensive,"
but there are all kinds of new
industries that are going to
come into being all the time.
So capital will flow eventually
into other industries and
they'll start out with big
profit margins,
and then the profit margins
will get competed away,
but then capital will so
somewhere else.
So unless you have this idea
that there's a sort of fixed
number of lines or production
such that once profits start to
fall in all of them they're
going to fall economy-wide,
there's no particular reason,
even working from Marx's own
premises,
to think that he's come up with
any lasting account of why the
rate of profit would fall in
capitalist systems.
Moreover, even putting that
problem to one side,
if you think about it,
even if it is the case that
making production more
capital-intensive reduces profit
margins in the long run,
nonetheless,
if productivity goes up at a
more rapid rate than capital
displaces labor in the
production process then you
wouldn't necessarily see the
rate of profit fall.
So if the rate of increase in
productivity exceeds the rate at
which capital is displacing
labor,
or to put it in Marx's jargon,
constant capital is displacing
variable capital,
then there's actually no reason
to expect the rate of profit to
fall.
So it all depends on how much
more productive capital makes
labor, and there's no
theoretical answer to that
question.
It's an empirical question.
So even though Marx thought
there was a declining tendency
in the rate of profit it's
debatable whether in fact there
is,
and it's certainly not the case
that his theory explained why it
should occur.
His third argument,
competition eliminates
competitors,
and because production is
becoming more and more capital
intensive,
entry costs are going up and
you're not going to see new
people coming in to the market.
I told the story about NASA and
the O-rings on the Challenger
blowing up.
There was nobody to come into
the market and take over then,
so you have a monopoly,
a not-very-efficient monopoly
producer who lacks the incentive
to innovate,
and we have the sorts of
problems we saw that developed
with Morton Thiokol in that
instance.
So that's also true only under
a fairly restrictive set of
assumptions which might not turn
out to be true.
After all, there are some
industries in which there are
economies of smallness.
Think about Apple Computers
invented in somebody's garage in
California completely upending
IBM and the big established
capital-intensive computer
firms,
and totally transforming that
market.
So it's not necessarily true.
Marx had in his mind
nineteenth-century industrial
production,
steel works,
cotton factories,
this sort of thing,
but it's a very
historically-bounded perception
of what it is that goes on in
economic systems.
And there might be all sorts of
sectors in the economy that tend
to resist the development of
monopolies,
and in which there are various
economies of smallness that
actually lend themselves to the
constant entry of new players
that keep revitalizing the
system.
And I think the information
technology revolution that has
accompanied your generation
would be exhibit A in defending
that proposition.
Under-consumption,
or sometimes it's said
over-production,
obviously it means the same
thing.
The way we put it into Marx's
sort of conceptual scheme was
the argument that the workers
collectively couldn't buy
everything they produced.
Smith believed that.
Ricardo believed that.
Marx believed that,
and early theories of
imperialism were partly dreamed
up in order to explain that;
that you get imperialism partly
as a result of the search for
new markets to address the
endemic weak demand in
capitalist systems.
Marx is not the only person who
thought there was endemic weak
demand in capitalist systems.
Indeed, Keynes,
the great English economist of
the first half of the twentieth
century,
and the theorist whose ideas
informed the policies to end the
Depression also thought there
was endemic weak demand in
capitalist systems because of a
diminishing marginal propensity
to consume.
Keynes' idea was if you have no
money and I give you a dollar
you'll spend it,
but if you have a million
dollars and I give you a dollar
you'll save it.
And so when you get into
recessions the problem is weak
demand,
and so you get the Keynesian
answer to recessions or
depressions is to spend money at
the bottom,
for governments to do that
largely through borrowing.
And this is,
of course, what first,
the George W. Bush
Administration in its final
year, and then the Obama
Administration in its first
year, have been doing.
A classic Keynesian response to
what's now being called The
Great Recession to prevent it
from becoming a great
depression.
Namely, the state borrows
money, tries to spend it in the
part of the economy that will
stimulate demand and then will
get the economy going back up.
So, again, this is an example
of Marx's chronic
underestimation of the capacity
of the state to do things that
will stave off crises,
or manage crises,
or prevent them from becoming
catastrophically bad.
And so I think we've seen a
vivid illustration of that in
the last couple of years.
Finally, working class
consciousness;
as all of these other things
were going on and making the
system creak at the joints and
become less and less functional,
Marx thought that the workers
would start to become a
class-for-itself.
The workers would start to see
that they were getting ripped
off and get angry about it,
become mobilized and militant,
and reach the point where they
believe that they had nothing to
lose but their chains.
Now there are two problems with
that.
One we already mentioned last
Wednesday.
This is that Marx was
half-right in thinking that
people judge their utility by
what others get.
They don't just ask the Reagan
question,
"Am I better off than I
was four years ago,"
they do pay attention to what
others get,
but they generally,
and this is the part where he
was wrong and a hundred years of
industrial sociology has now
pretty much established this,
they tend to compare themselves
to similarly-situated people.
So workers in the auto industry
compare themselves to steel
workers or coal workers,
not to the executives who run
the firms in which they actually
work,
and that's true up and down the
occupational scale.
I think I mentioned a professor
would be much more upset to
learn that their salary is five
thousand dollars less than the
professor in the next office
than they will be to learn that
their salary is five hundred
thousand dollars less than the
attorney who lives down the
street.
People compare themselves to
others, but to
similarly-situated others,
not to people very far from
them in the socioeconomic order.
And so that kind of militancy
doesn't eventuate.
More importantly,
Marx actually conflates the
relative immiseration of the
proletariat with the absolute
immiseration of the proletariat.
So if we went back through the
slides and we went back to the
discussion of the theory of
exploitation,
remember when we did that
little exercise and we saw that
you would all actually agree to
be more exploited on his
definition than less exploited
when you had the choice of
either going to a ten-hours
working day with new technology
or an eleven-hours working day
without it.
But that measure was a relative
measure.
It was what you get as a
proportion of the total surplus
as compared with what the
capitalist gets.
It wasn't an absolute measure,
and we saw that it's perfectly
possible for the rate of
exploitation,
as he defines it,
to go up while the level of
wages remains constant or even
increases.
So wages might be going up as
well as exploitation at the same
time.
Well, but if that's true you're
never going to reach absolute
immiseration.
You're never going to actually
reach the point where workers
are literally falling into
poverty.
And if it's the absolute
immiseration that has to trigger
the militant action,
the working class
consciousness,
it's not going to happen.
And indeed, here again Marx
greatly underestimated what
governments can do to make sure
that the workers don't reach the
point where they have nothing to
lose but their chains.
In the 1950s,
an English Marxian political
economist called Ralph Miliband,
whose son now is a British
cabinet member,
by the way, David Miliband,
and is the likely next leader
of the Labor Party after they
lose the elections in May to
David Cameron.
David Miliband's father,
Ralph, wrote a book called
The State in Capitalist
Society in the 1950s--
I think it was 1954 but don't
hold me to it--
in which he said,
"The welfare state is
capitalism's best friend."
The right always attacks the
welfare state,
but it's capitalism's best
friend because it buys off
working class discontent,
and it ensures that workers
have a stake in the existing
order,
and that they will never reach
this preverbal situation where
they have nothing to lose but
their chains.
So when you work your way
through this macro theory it's
riddled with holes and doesn't
add up to the collapse of
capitalism and not,
therefore, particularly
surprising that capitalism
didn't collapse in the ways that
Marx predicted.
But now let's dig in a little
bit more to the micro theory,
and the micro foundations of
Marx's thinking,
because I think this is where
we will find some interesting
lessons for our own project in
this course going forward.
At the heart of the micro
theory is the labor theory of
value, and we're going to say
something about three aspects of
it.
We're going to talk about
Marx's assumptions about living
human labor,
the moral argument behind the
labor theory of value,
which many people you will find
in this room find appealing
despite the problems with the
labor theory of value,
and then some alternative
formulations of what it is that
he was trying to do.
If you think back to when we
were doing the exposition of the
labor theory of value I said
that Marx defends it,
living human labor-power as a
source of value,
by saying it's the only thing
that creates fresh surplus
value, okay?
So one difficulty is,
and John Roemer points this out
in that piece that I had you
read, it ignores the
contribution of dead workers.
That living workers,
for instance,
when we talked about the
introduction of machinery,
the spinning jenny or whatever,
what about the workers who made
the spinning jenny?
Aren't they part of this
calculation?
Aren't they being exploited
either by the capitalist or by
the living workers who use the
spinning jenny?
So if you took it seriously
you'd have to say those
exploitation indexes are way too
simple because they don't
capture the contribution of dead
workers.
But then a second thing it
doesn't capture,
the labor theory value assumes
the capitalist contributes what,
nothing?
But why isn't it the case that
the labor that the capitalist
performs also goes into the
creation of the surplus?
And again, I think you've got
to imagine,
get yourself back into this
nineteenth-century mindset where
intellectual work doesn't seem
particularly important.
You're just running these big
factories.
But, of course,
when we think about what the
role of entrepreneurial ideas is
in the creation of productive
systems,
it's absurd to say that the
work of the capitalist doesn't
contribute anything to the value
of what's produced.
But then you get into the
problem,
well, how do you discover what
is the result of the work of the
worker and what is the result of
the work of capitalist,
and there's no mechanism for
dealing with that.
And then what about the fact
that the worker in Marx's
typical model has a spouse at
home feeding him,
making his sandwiches as he
goes to the factory and so on
and so forth.
What about the spouse at home?
Why is it just the worker who's
being exploited?
And various theorists have said
if you take Marxism seriously on
its own premises,
it seems that,
again, just as with the dead
worker,
the stay-at-home spouse is
either being exploited
indirectly by the capitalist or
is being exploited by the worker
who goes to work for whom she is
doing unpaid labor.
And so we've had a series of
feminist critiques of the labor
theory of value.
And this gets recognized in
daily life.
There is a very interesting
1986 divorce case in the State
of New York in which a couple
had gotten married,
he had gone to medical school,
she had stayed at home and
darned his socks and made
sandwiches for him,
and helped him through medical
school.
Anyway, many years later they
get divorced.
And apart from the usual issues
in the divorce,
the court said that the
stay-at-home wife had a property
interest in her husband's
medical practice that was a
byproduct of the work that she
had put into it by darning his
socks and making his sandwiches,
and he went to class and built
up his practice.
And so they awarded her a forty
percent property interest in the
practice and required him to
maintain life insurance in her
name for the rest of his life so
that her property interest could
be protected.
So what you can see once you
start to do this,
you know, I've just given three
areas where this runs into
trouble,
once you take seriously the
idea that labor-power,
the capacity to work,
is the source of value,
why zero-in in this
monomaniacal way on what one
worker does in the production
process?
What about all of the others
who contribute to the
productivity of the process
either directly as with the
capitalist or indirectly?
And of course once you make
this point about the
stay-at-home spouse,
what about the Sunday school
teacher that drummed the work
ethic into the worker?
Didn't that Sunday school
teacher contribute something to
the productivity of the worker
and so on?
So you're going to get this
huge web of indecipherable
entangled entitlements if you're
trying to trace out who
contributed what work to the
creation of something of value.
More fundamentally let's dig
into the assumption that making
creates entitlements.
After all, for Marx this is
what seems to give the theory
its ideological edge.
As I said, it's a secular
version of Locke's workmanship.
It's the claim that workers
produce something for which
they're not compensated.
They produce something and the
capitalist takes it,
right?
That's the claim.
And when we were doing the
exposition of that I said that
what differentiates labor-power
from all other commodities is
that it's necessary for the
production of every commodity.
It's the common denominator of
all commodities.
Remember I gave you the example;
I said if I have a certain
amount of money and I spend it
on a meal,
I consume the meal and it's
gone, whereas if I spend it
paying somebody to paint my
house,
at the end of having consumed
their labor-power I have a more
valuable house.
If I go to sell the house I'm
going to get more from it than I
would have gotten but for not
having had it painted.
And so that's the idea that the
consumption of living human
labor-power leads to the
creation of fresh exchange
value,
whereas mere consumption of a
meal doesn't.
Terrible argument.
What's wrong with it?
Nobody can see what's wrong
with it?
Come on.
It's a terrible argument,
hopelessly bad argument,
anybody?
Yes, ma'am?
Student: Could the meal's value
be that it keeps you alive?
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Say a little more.
You're dead right.
Student: So the meal,
even though you can only use it
once, it is necessary for the
sustained value of yourself.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Okay, and just take that
thought a little further.
Where does it go?
You're dead right.
Student: So the value is
constant, or something?
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Well, not exactly,
but the point is it's just
wrong to say when I consume that
food it goes,
because after all I have more
calories of energy which I could
then use to paint my own house
with, let's say.
Of course I might sit on the
couch and watch the Super Bowl
and just get fat,
but that's my own decision,
right?
I can use that energy to paint
the house.
So a very interesting Cambridge
economist called Piero Sraffa
wrote a book called The
Production of Commodities by
Means of Commodities.
Even though it's about an
80-page book,
it took him thirty years to
write.
That's a whole different story
which I don't have time to go
into.
But this is what he said that's
of interest to us.
He said, "Imagine an
economy that has three
commodities, corn,
books, food,
I'm sorry, corn,
books, labor.
Corn is food;
corn, books and labor.
Yes, it's true that it takes
labor to produce corn and to
produce books.
Yes it's true that it does not
take books to produce corn or
labor, but it's not true that it
doesn't require corn to produce
labor and books.
So corn, or food,
or anything that's necessary
for the production of
labor-power is going to have the
same property that labor-power
has.
It's going to be present
necessarily, directly or
indirectly, in all lines of
production.
And so Sraffa said,
based on that idea,
you can do a corn theory of
value for this economy that will
have exactly the same
mathematical properties as the
labor theory of value,
and then you can have your
theory of the exploitation of
corn by capital,
the rate of exploitation of
corn by capital that will be
exactly analogous to the rate of
the exploitation of labor by
capital.
There's no difference,
mathematically identical.
Why is that interesting to us?
It's interesting to us because
it shows you that whatever Marx
says about exploitation merely
being a technical notion,
it's not.
It's a moral idea.
Colloquially we talk about the
exploitation of natural
resources, but we don't say that
the corn owns what was produced
with the corn.
We don't say the corn was
exploited in the way the worker
was exploited,
we just don't.
Think about an intermediate
case;
the horse down a mineshaft in a
coalmine hauling trucks of coal
from the face to the elevator
that's going to take it out.
We could do the whole Marxian
story.
We could say the horse covers
the cost of its feed in the
first hour of the day,
and it works ten-hour days,
so the other nine hours it's
producing surplus that accrues
to somebody other than the
horse.
Is the horse exploited?
Yes?
No?
Nobody thinks the horse isn't
exploited.
So a much trickier case,
and the reason it's tricky is
some people are much more open
to the idea of animal rights
than others, right?
So Locke said animals were the
waste of God put there for our
use, but we're not that
hard-hearted,
some of us.
So if you think of the horse as
in some sense a kind of moral
agent then it's not a happy
thing that it's being exploited
in this sense.
But whether or not we want to
say the exploitation is unjust--
not just cruel if the horse is
suffering,
but unjust--depends upon some
prior idea that creatures are
entitled to the product of their
labor.
That's the workmanship idea.
And that is why even if you
reject the labor theory of
value, you're still left with
this nagging idea that there's
something to workmanship.
Most people are not going to
want to totally get rid of
workmanship.
If I write a book I think,
"I put all that blood,
sweat, and tears into that
book, it's mine.
It's mine, my work."
Somebody takes it,
"You've stolen something
that I made."
It's a very powerful thing in
people.
But not everybody accepts it,
right?
Not everybody accepts this
idea, this very
individualist-centric conception
that we own what we make.
We have this kind of
exclusive--to go back to the
language of Locke in The
First Treatise,
that God made us with the
capacity to be miniature gods,
to have the same ownership
rights over what we make as he
has over his creation.
Look at Chief Seattle.
He has a very different view.
"This we know:
the earth does not belong to
man, man belongs to the earth.
All things are connected like
the blood that unites us all.
Man did not weave the web of
life, he is merely a strand in
it.
Whatever he does to the web,
he does to himself."
Very different view of the
world and our place in it;
not man-centric.
One of the reasons we start
this course with Locke is this
is where the individualism comes
from.
It's this workmanship ideal.
Doesn't look individualist at
all in Locke's formulation
because at the end of the day,
it's a theological argument;
it's an argument about God
having maker's rights over his
whole creation.
But it's the move of saying we
are miniature gods that can
behave in a god-like fashion,
and then secularizing it,
which leads to the
individualism.
Or consider something that
Robert Nozick,
a writer we're going to read
later in the class,
pretty soon,
actually, starting next week--
he makes fun of the labor
theory of value.
He says, Why does mixing one's
labor with something make one
the owner of it?
Perhaps because one owns one's
labor (self-ownership,
if you like),
and so one comes to own a
previously unowned thing that
becomes permeated with what one
owns.
Ownership seeps over into the
rest.
But why isn't mixing what I own
with what I don't own a way of
losing what I own rather than a
way of gaining what I don't?
If I own a can of tomato juice
and spill it into the sea,
so that its molecules (made
radioactive,
so I can check this) mingle
evenly throughout the sea,
do I thereby come to own the
sea, or have I foolishly
dissipated my tomato juice?
Why is it that we want to say
when I put effort and energy
into something that it's mine?
Very, very perplexing and
tricky thing and we will come
back to it in considerably more
detail later in the course when
we read John Rawls,
because interestingly it's not
until we get to John Rawls that
we find anyone who's really
willing to radically question
workmanship and the
self-ownership postulate that
goes with it.
Okay, so Marxism seems
problematic, so what's left?
And I think there are really
two main things left.
One is a negative argument that
comes out of Marxism,
rather than any of its positive
claims,
and that is the fact that his
theory of exploitation fails
doesn't mean that he lacks a
good critique of markets as
distributors of either good or
harms in society.
We could go back to our story
about Trump and the bag lady,
for example.
The Pareto superior result in
that example,
if you remember,
was for the bag lady to die
because there was no Pareto
superior exchange that could
occur between Trump and the bag
lady.
Markets reflect the
inequalities that come into
them, but they don't give any
account of the justice of those
inequalities.
So there's this problem,
if you like,
of the tyranny of the status
quo, and we saw that in the
economic realm with the analysis
of that problem,
and in the political realm when
we talked about the corn dealer
problem with Mill,
right?
That the market systems are
biased towards the status quo,
but market principles are
purely procedural principles.
They tell you nothing about how
you got the status quo,
and so there's a kind of
garbage-in/garbage-out problem
with market systems.
Nozick, we will see,
makes this point explicit when
he says any remotely plausible
theory of justice is going to
have to have three parts,
a theory of justice in
acquisition (i.e.
a theory of staring points),
a theory of justice in transfer
(i.e.
a theory of exchanges),
and a theory of the
rectification of past injustice
(i.e.
a theory for addressing
accumulated injustices of the
past).
And Nozick will,
for reasons which we will go
into, thinks he has accounts of
all of those things.
But it's the negative argument
of Marxism, that markets are not
justified by reference to the
failure of Marx's own
alternative theory,
is good.
If you're going to have a
justification for the
distribution that occurs through
markets it's going to have to be
something else.
It's going to have to be
provided.
Maybe it can be provided,
but so far in the utilitarian
and neoclassical traditions it
hasn't been provided.
So there's a kind of unfinished
agenda there that's put on the
table by the Marxian critique of
markets even though Marx's
answer to that problem,
is unconvincing.
And then I think secondly what
Marxism leaves us to address is
not an argument about the
sources of value.
The labor theory of value is
just a hopeless analytical mess,
and can't be resuscitated.
There's no way to fix the labor
theory of value.
But there is an argument about
freedom.
Remember where we started;
I said unlike the conventional
wisdom that Marx is an
egalitarian, no.
He's a theorist of freedom.
His utopian ideal is a world in
which the free development of
each is the condition for the
free development of all,
where our labor in not
alienated.
We saw that the utopian version
of that is unsustainable.
Nonetheless,
Marx's definition of class,
when you think about it,
is really an argument about
freedom.
When he says you're working
class if you have to sell your
labor power to somebody else in
order to live,
it's the compulsion,
right?
It's the compulsion.
It's not whether you choose to.
I like lecturing here having a
captive audience of people who
have to listen to me ramble on
endlessly.
It makes me feel good,
but that's not what makes me
working class,
right?
It's that I have to work for
somebody else in order to
survive.
It's that element of compulsion.
That's your lack of freedom.
So as Roemer puts it in the
essay that I put on the
syllabus, it's that there's a
class monopoly of the means of
production which creates that
power;
that some people have the power
to insist that other people work
for them.
So it's really not about the
calculus of contributions and
who puts what,
and whether the rate of
exploitation's two point
three-three,
or one point six or anything.
It's not about that.
It's really about the
distribution of power in the
production process.
And if we're going to take
anything from Marx that is of
enduring value it's going to be
an argument about power.
It's going to be an argument
which says that a world in which
we organize things so that one
class effectively has power to
control a different class's
behavior,
that is an unjust world.
And much of the neo-Marxist
literature that people take
seriously jettisons the labor
theory of value and explores
this power-based argument as the
root of what it was Marx was
trying to get at with the
concept of exploitation.
See you on Monday.